[Music]
hey what's up everybody yeah hopefully
you guys had a good new years and he's
been frustrated all day god damn it i
know everything's going on well here's
the yeah well here's the thing well this
is why okay so one of the reasons that
we're doing the show at five instead of
three like we normally would
is because you said you wanted to go for
a motorcycle ride yeah go buy the bike
and go buy the biker bar and you wanted
more time to do it because you didn't
get up until noon yeah i do what i do so
i know i'm just saying but so i mean
i've been up since 8 30 so to me to me
it seemed like you're
yeah so so he goes there and then it
turned out that they were closing early
because of something like some someone a
friend of theirs like died and they were
doing like a wake or something yeah so
he came back early but then he was like
oh well i ate at the mexican restaurant
and i was like well i was thinking about
ordering some dominoes which you already
ate so i'll get some dominoes so i
called domino's at like
quarter to three yeah and just ordered
like a sandwich and a salad and some
[ __ ] and they were like oh well you know
the deliveries are kind of behind today
and i was like okay whatever that's fine
and uh then
it's hours and hours and hours went by
and i'm just kind of like um are you
guys still breaking the food or what's
going on
and uh so i have not eaten anything
cause i'm getting really hangry right
now i haven't eaten a single thing like
all day today i've had one cup of coffee
and that's it yeah there's food in the
house could have gone on any guys i know
but it's like no i was well you ate out
i was i wanted to eat out too i was like
oh i want to you know eat something
different so i was like oh i just kind
of said you know salad and sandwich kind
of sounded good and i was like and
they'll bring it but then they didn't
bring it i had them delicious mexican
fajitas yeah so it's like so i don't
know what i'm gonna do now i have real
authentic mexicans i'm gonna have to
like just go down and get some chinese
food or something
you know we'll take you somewhere get
you something on the show man that's
like lame i got invited to a birthday
party too whose birthday there's some
some chick named cowgirl got [ __ ] i
got that's her name cowgirl girl i got
she's a biker girl she i got i got
invited to cowgirl's 70th birthday for
her 70th birthday she was there she's
handed out flyers i want i just i'm
going to invite you my birthday party
oh okay she's got [ __ ] cows and
horses and [ __ ] and she said and she
said her her husband used to have the
birthday she used to have it you know uh
on she used to have oysters a big oyster
event on her birthday but he died so
then she transferred it to her birthday
party you know
her set you know every year so she hands
out all these flyers goes to all the
[ __ ] biker bars and all the bikes she
says you can camp there there's gonna be
bands you can bring your own booze they
got are you gonna go i don't know
i don't know
she was cool
it's gonna be country music you know how
it is
yeah it's gonna be listening to free
bird every 20 minutes of [ __ ] yeah no
thanks yeah and the [ __ ] but she's
headed out flyers and some of those guys
said oh yeah i went to your last one you
know but it's just old by she had her
damn bandana on and her [ __ ]
fingerless gloves and she's 70. on her
[ __ ] harley
well you know that's cool that's what
they do whatever that's what they do
all right you can shoot you can figure
out she's got a place where you can go
shooting there and you got everything
you know sure and you can camp there
she says you don't have a shower but she
has a bathroom
well that well that's good well those
are those farms when they do like dig a
latrine out there
most most barns have plumbing you've
been there when i worked yeah don't know
i know i'm just kidding
uh yeah all right so let's since we're
already late and i'm starving let's
let's talk about the movie
so this is willard from 1971.
uh somebody asked earlier didn't they
make a sequel to this called ben yes
they did and uh michael jackson had that
song about it
uh was it was in the movie that was yeah
that song that was 1972. willard is
1971. now they also remade willard
in 2003
i think it was early 2000s with pr with
uh crispin glover yeah which um
i actually saw that one fairly recently
i've seen it a couple times i'm gonna
say
this might be this might be one of the
very few situations that i like the
remake better than the original the
original is pretty good
but i don't know if i would call it a
horror movie necessarily because even
though it's ostensibly a killer rat
movie
um the rats are so damn cute that they
really don't
they don't they don't really come off as
like scary or threatening yeah i'm gonna
go as far to say that this wasn't a good
movie i mean and well it could be just
me too because i'm not afraid of rats
like i i actually quite like rats so um
so they are not scary to me like even in
large quantities
so maybe that's what it was too but just
you know what i mean like the you know
the rats are cute so i was just kind of
like this it'd be like attack of the
killer hamsters kind of yeah that's
that's kind of what i was thinking yes
to me the movie was very much kind of
like it's it's early 70s yeah 71 but it
feels like almost early 60s the way the
movie's filmed
it's it's pretty canned
um the acting is just not good the the
[Music]
it's just very generic to me and it's
not scary it's not a horror movie it's
not
it's i could see how okay whenever i
first heard about this i was a kid and i
could i heard people you know kids on
the playground like you're in the third
and fourth grade talking about this damn
movie when this movie really wasn't all
that old during the times i'm talking
about maybe 77 76 when i heard about
this
and they would talk about this like this
is some kind of frightening ass [ __ ]
subversive
movie that your parents wouldn't let you
watch typed it was bad [ __ ] there really
wasn't anything to it
yeah there's no gore um there's not and
honestly like even some of the like rat
attacks and stuff like that are just
like
mostly the rats are just kind of like to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up it's like they don't really
kill anybody till the end psycho's much
better and much older
and and and
they were showing that on television
when i was a kid i found a lot of psycho
and it scared me you know whoa you know
weird [ __ ] this one is just
it's kind of it's okay but it's not a
horror movie yeah and you don't really
know what they're talking about
it's kind of culturally distant
you don't know if they're trying to kind
of creatively tell you that he's gay
that the main character he wasn't though
because he was interested in uh the temp
that he worked with it's played by
sandra locke but was he is hard to tell
yes i guess he was supposed to be they
were just trying to make a guy
they're trying to portray this kid as
being weird and very frustrating he was
just awkward and it doesn't really work
not today's standards um you know they
haven't they don't know weird kids like
we know him today
[ __ ] he just comes across as just
socially awkward and um
sort of like passive and introverted
that's kind of more what they were
trying to get across i think
um but yeah bruce davison plays willard
this was actually based on a book
called rapman's notebooks
and um so yeah so he plays this kind of
he's supposed to be i think he's
supposed to be in his late 20s right i
think he's like 27 or 28.
and i guess what ended up happening he
lives in this big old rambling uh house
with his mom who's played by elsa
lanchester of a bride of frankenstein
fame i didn't even realize she was still
alive like in the in the early 1970s she
was she's quite old but uh yeah she
plays his mom
and she's just your stereotypical
you know
oh my god why why can't you be like this
and why can't you do it she's like she's
a piece of work and so he lives there
and i guess what happened was that their
dad
had um started this manufacturing
company and after the dad died
his partner i'm assuming he's played by
ernest borgnine took over the company
and essentially like took most of their
money
and then he sort of like i don't know if
he demoted willard to some kind of lowly
position but he's always like
um he's always kind of like [ __ ] on
the kid
um and
and then like william and all
willard's mom's like
cr like cantankerous old people friends
are always kind of like telling him you
need to be more aggressive and you need
to tell that guy what for and you need
to do this and that the other thing
so it's kind of this whole like uh bad
situation where everyone's telling them
that he's not
you know he's not good enough or
whatever and so then like the house is
falling apart and then his mom's
bitching about that like why don't you
fix this and why don't you fix that and
why don't you do this and all this other
[ __ ] and so then like there's some rats
in the backyard and he befriends them
and then
before too long he has a whole bunch of
them and he has them kind of trained so
then he starts like sending them out to
like cause chaos is that that's a thing
at people's parties like who he doesn't
like and [ __ ] like that as if that's
possible
well you know rats are very smart yeah
but
if this was possible people would be
doing it
i would totally be doing it this is like
some cool super villain sharing yeah it
kind of
strange
strange credulity you know that that
that the rats remember things and that
the rats know what the hell's going on
and they obey commands
it's just not
i can it's just a it's just a it's a
it's a storytelling device you know it's
something that you can sell a movie on
be good in a movie poster but
it's just not done right where you would
believe it you know
uh not in this version like i wouldn't
mind seeing the crispin glover version
baby i actually the crisp and glover one
i remember that being much more horror
themed it's much darker yeah it's weird
because i saw willard
as a kid
and i remembered some [ __ ] about it like
i remember it's kind of stood out to me
and that's why i wanted to kind of see
it again because i saw that they had it
for free on amazon prime the interesting
thing about the original willard is that
as i said it's not really it's listed as
a horror movie but it's not really it's
kind of more
a drama sort of with almost like comedic
elements but it's almost all
like shot in the daytime
so there's not really any
you know there's not really that many
kind of scary scenes of like ooh like
the rats coming out of or every i don't
know it just all seemed
especially when he like releases all the
rats at uh ernest borgnine's party
that's just almost played for laughs
like it's almost like farcical because
it's just kind of like all these rats
running around all over this food and
everybody wigging out and trying to hit
him with brooms and [ __ ] so there's that
so it's almost kind of like funny
until you get to the end when and
honestly like i said the rats only kill
one person right i mean they only kill
ernest borgnine at the end um you know
which that's a pretty effective scene
but honestly that's kind of the only one
that has any kind of like horror
or suspense kind of adjacent thing to it
up to then it was pretty much just kind
of like
almost funny
you know
uh
it's just generally generate
generationally it just didn't get me to
me it just felt a lot like
it almost felt like rebel without a
cause but with rats
but with rats yeah and i didn't and i
don't i couldn't tell you what rebel
without a cause is about
you know it was like
my parents generation they [ __ ] loved
the movie i watched it and i really
didn't have anything to take away from
it you know i couldn't really i didn't
really get anything out of it um this
movie kind of was like that for me
it's like okay it's kind of like rebel
without a cause but this guy's got rats
and they're and they're gonna kill
people and get get vengeance it's just
not effectively shown the story is not
effectively told or shown it's just
it's almost kind of like a
kind of has a star trek
kind of
sequel no not star trek it almost felt
like an old episode of adam 12 or
something
if you know what that is it's just
it felt like old tv
yeah i kind of lo well like a lot of
movies in the 70s that weren't kind of
like big like auteur movies to kind of
feel like that to me i guess and the
director of this um daniel mann he
actually did a lot of really good he did
a lot of movies that were
um that were kind of based on
uh plays like tea house of the august
moon and stuff and he also did uh
butterfield eight wasn't elizabeth
taylor in that and he made uh our man
flint which actually i quite liked in
1966 it's kind of like a spy parody
um he did that so he did like a [ __ ] ton
of movies and stuff this one i don't
know it just seemed like
it took a while
i don't know i kept i think i kept
waiting for it to get get scary maybe
i feel like the sequel to this ben
i'm sure i saw that too maybe that one
was scarier than this one and maybe i'm
confusing the two because i saw them so
long ago if anybody's seen ben recently
let me know because
i kind of feel like some of the scenes
that i thought were from this
were
maybe from that one and maybe that one
is scarier the only thing like one thing
that really kind of upset me when i was
watching this was the two i mean he has
like willard has like a [ __ ] ton of rats
but
there's two that he has that are his
particular favorites uh one of which is
ben
and one of which is socrates who was
like a white rat
and uh he takes those two to work and
like he hides him in the file room or
whatever and uh somebody finds them
and ernest borgnine he actually ends up
killing socrates and that like really
upset me because like you know what i
mean because you know how i am about
like animals and movies and i know it's
not real and [ __ ] like that but he's
like poking at the rat and it's like all
covered with blood and i was like no not
socrates so i was like way more into the
rats i guess than the people yeah and um
[Laughter]
because the rats were cute as [ __ ] i
thought
i was like ooh look at them they can do
all these like little tricks and they're
like running inside his bag and going to
work with him i'm like that's darling
they're not scary no they're adorable
yeah well there's something there's
something about just the just the acting
and just the formatting the formatting
of this movie
it's it's a movie of its time and it
just didn't i just
it just didn't do anything for me
yeah i didn't love it um you know it
kept my interest but
it was there was definitely a little
something weird about it that i couldn't
really put my finger on
honestly the crispin glover one you
would probably dig that because well
crispin glover is always fun to watch
because he's
because he's uh weird as [ __ ]
and i think that they went more full-on
into
the weird horror thing in the remake
where i feel like the original was kind
of supposed to be a horror movie like
killer rap movie
but it wasn't really a horror movie you
know what i mean like it didn't have
hardly any horror elements to it which
defeated the purpose yeah it's just kind
of like i thought the movie was tame and
just kind of boring yeah like it wasn't
real gory like i said the rats only
killed one person
and it didn't really get
like even remotely dark until the end
you know what i mean when
ernest borgnine's character gets killed
by the rats and then
uh willard is like oh [ __ ] now he's got
to like get rid of all these rats i
guess because he doesn't want to get
blamed so he starts like drowning them
and stuff so that was like upsetting but
up to that it just seemed like
most of it was him kind of like playing
with the rats and interacting with the
rats and kind of
uh maybe trying to get together with
this temp that worked at his office he
was played by sandra locke who was
married to clint eastwood for a little
while i think
back in the old days
um but yeah so a lot of it was that and
then a lot of it was like ernest
borgnine and i love ernest borgnine um i
think he's probably him and the rats
were the best part of this but ernest
borgnine going around just being a total
like [ __ ] [ __ ] weasel to everybody
that was like pretty funny but
i don't know like and it was just i
don't know
the whole like relationship was weird
too between
willard and his mom
like she like his mom was really weird
and then like he had all those friends
like his mom had that weird friend that
was like a real busybody and she kept
like just [ __ ] showing up at the
house and oh by the way your mom died so
i'm gonna be over here like going
through all your [ __ ] you know what i
mean because he had like all kind of
financial problems and [ __ ] so that it
go the movie goes a lot into that you
know what i'm saying
but um somebody said earlier
that they had read
the book and that there's a lot that the
books are actually really good there's a
lot of like psychological backstory in
there i kind of feel like this needed
more of that
you know what i mean i mean it just kind
of it didn't really go into his
psychology and he didn't seem that weird
to me
he's not like crisp and glove or weird
no he was just a little bit awkward he
was just like a little bit shy he wasn't
like
evil mastermind or nothing he's just
he's not that good of an actor
maybe that's what it is he i think i
think he got better because he was in
some other [ __ ] later on when he was a
little bit older yeah this might have
been like one of his very trying to do
like some weird guy that doesn't really
come off as a weird guy yeah that's what
i mean he didn't really come off and
come off as that weird so he wasn't
really all that threatening and then
rats are not threatening because they
were cute
and smart and everything so i kind of
feel like they it was just that
i feel like they should have focused if
they wanted to make it like scary or
like suspenseful they should have like
shifted the focus
onto you know something else what was
that other killer rap movie this was it
food of the gods yeah yeah they got big
in that one oh that's right yeah yeah
that was based up well very loosely
based on an h.2 wealth story
which was also didn't they do they did a
movie on mystery science theater where
those teenagers got really big yeah
that's right what the [ __ ] was that
called that was also very loosely based
on food i said the movie's very 1960s
feel to me uh and they
in the 1960s their idea of trying to
tell a story of a weird teenager is
basically you're going to end up check
off from star trek or like somebody like
the monkeys you know
robert nezmuth from the monkeys you say
oh that's so weird no he's not it's just
well it just didn't really happen it
might be a reference yeah that that's
what i was gonna say i just feel like
back then
in a movie you didn't have to be that
weird for everybody to be like weird
nowadays you gotta go way out there with
the weirdness because otherwise people's
like yeah and yeah
that you have a bowl haircut
right it's just it's funny because you
say man you know hey what's up man oh
you're weird
yeah and it's it's funny too because i
see some movies from like the 60s like
you said
um
from you know that ron mystery science
theater that have like you know people
that were like beatniks or something and
they're talking about like how weird or
how counter cultural these people are
i'm like not really i mean they're not
really that different than
a normal person yeah i can't even if i
saw like two of them walking down next
to like a square and like a [ __ ]
beatnik or whatever it's like it would
make a difference it would yeah i mean
nowadays you wouldn't really know the
difference but i guess back then it was
a big deal so i think that's maybe what
it was because the guy didn't he just
came across as like a little shy and
introverted he didn't come across as
like a weirdo or anything you know he
was just like a little bit
yeah now the norman bates character kind
of came across as pretty weird
but not not unbelievable yeah i mean you
could believe that yeah that's what made
him that was a good character yeah i
mean anthony perkins did a [ __ ] great
job of doing because he came across as
really weird like there's something to
matter with this dude but also kind of
sympathetic and like you could see how
somebody could
you know would want to be friends with
him or because he seemed like nice but
because he didn't seem creepy but i
don't know it's kind of hard people are
forgotten every one of those psycho
movies is good there's like four of them
or five of them yeah we did didn't we do
a um i think we did a review on all four
of them because i think i could i bought
them yeah because i told you i was like
if you seen the first one i was like all
of them are good yeah that you think
that they get what you think that it
would get bad as they win they do
they're all they're all totally like the
last two were like some of the best ones
honestly i think the second one is my
favorite but um out of the sequels i
mean obviously the first one's my
favorite but i mean the second one is so
so good the only other series that was
like that was uh fantastic phantasm yeah
phantasm got better as it went wherever
where every single one of them was like
worth watching you know what i mean yeah
because usually after the second or
third one you're just like [ __ ] gonna
need to see anymore but yeah those ones
those ones i think those are those are
creations of love
that was
you know the creation i think one of
them was done by a studio i think that
was two or three two two it was number
one and it was still good still good and
then it reverted back to the property
owner and [ __ ] he did a great job
with them i mean gotta love reg yeah and
reg [ __ ] was a character that
actually grew and they and that reg
actually had a mythos and there's a lore
to the movies
and the
[ __ ] phantasm is a masterpiece you
just don't hear much about it because
they're indie films they're not big
studio films
guy tell just tells a great story he
says one of my best friends old man
looked like anthony perkins tall dark
and skinny he had a lady scream and
faint in a bank when she saw him right
after the movie came out
oh my god grant there's hammer also said
there's a bates motel in yale oregon i
always was afraid to stay there
they should go full on and with the like
norman bates experience you know what i
mean like don't actually kill the people
obviously like that are staying there
but you could do like some cool [ __ ]
like have people kind of creeping around
outside and you could stay but i mean
you know you could you could
advertise it as that it's like oh get
the psycho experience like stay in this
hotel and make it look the same and
stuff i would stay there that would be
cool
all right so uh are we gonna like wrap
it up because yeah we can wrap it up
because like i said
i'm i'm so hungry
but yeah
i haven't eaten all day long and i'm
just like so i'm getting angry but yeah
so uh if you want to watch willard if
you haven't seen in a long time it's on
amazon prime for free i think it's also
on to be for free
so check it out and uh we will be back
tomorrow
talking about another movie so have a
good rest of your weekend you guys and
we'll see you guys tomorrow
bye